so Leah you are a Jewish survivor from
Holland with the last name Frank but
there is no relation that you're aware
of married name we spoke last week and I
asked you if you had ever seen this film
and you had the perfect response to my
question do you remember what it was I
don't remember if I I know I saw it but
I I asked if you'd seen the film to me
and I don't need to see the film to know
what it's all about yeah I think what
you said to me was I don't need to see
it I lived it so let's so I wanted to
talk to you so Leah if you didn't read
her biography in the in the in the guide
as a survivor from Holland she was in
hiding she sort of represents the the
embodiment of Anne and other other Dutch
survivors and victims what I want to
talk about with you Leah is you're
you're a different experience in the
Franks the Franks work otto made a
decision to keep that family together
we're going to survive together or
perish together your family made a
different decision can you tell us about
what happened with you and how you were
separated from your sister and family my
parents made probably the most difficult
decision of their lives to let us
my sister myself leave the house and be
put into hiding
separate separate from them and separate
from each other and this happened today
after my seventh birthday
it so happens my sister and I share the
same birthday was three years apart so
she was my birthday gift and we were
taken away one day after the day after
our birthday April 18th 1943 which is
when we went into hiding first we were
put into a trance at home from where we
do their organization mostly student
organizations located some people found
some people that were willing to take in
Jewish children
for the duration worth nobody realized
it was going to take years were you
upset at your parents because you were
separated from them at that age no
because when we left a home
it was friends of a good friends of our
parents who picked us up so it was not
traumatic at that point we were told we
were going away for a few days and we
would see each other again in a few days
but the people that took us on the back
of the bicycles where we called him
uncle and aunt because they were my
parents best friends